el congreso chileno aprobó Este martes
por amplia mayoría la ley que reduce la
jornada laboral para los chilenos de 45
horas actuales a 40 horas semanales fue
en la cámara de diputados donde 127
diputados votaron a favor 14 lo hicieron
en contra y hubo tres abstenciones el
último trámite legislativo de una ley
que tardó 6 años en pasar por el
congreso y que tardará 5 en
implementarse puesto que contempla una
implementación paulatina se reducirá en
el primer año de su puesta en marcha de
45 a 44 horas semanales pasará a 42 en
el plazo de dos años siguientes y de ahí
a las 40 horas en un plazo de 5 años sin
embargo según adelantó la ministra de
trabajo Janeth Jara cuya labor fue
incansable para conseguir que la ley
saliera adelante dependerá de los
acuerdos particulares entre las empresas
y sus empleadores que la implementación
de la ley pueda agilizarse y ponerse en
marcha antes de esos cinco años que
establece la normativa también en
algunos casos concretos se podría
valorar la posibilidad de que hubiera
cuatro días de trabajo y tres de
descanso buena jornada muy emotiva en el
congreso donde hubo cánticos alegría
lágrimas y emoción entre ellas las de la
secretaria vocera general del gobierno
Camila Vallejo quien fue una de las
impulsoras de esta norma en el 2017
cuando se encontraba en el parlamento
como diputada comunista estaba tan
emocionada que no Pudo realizar
declaraciones es uno de los éxitos del
gobierno del presidente Gabriel Boris
fue una de sus promesas de campaña y se
espera que la ley se promulgue antes del
1 de Mayo